notre invitation vous êtes représentant
de l'ANEB
l'Association nationale des élus de
bassins et donc
nous avons monsieur le Président
Monsieur Bruno Forel Monsieur Frédéric
molossi qui est donc le vice-président
le Président je sais pas si c'est et
puis Madame Catherine grémillier qui est
la directrice et donc
comme vous le savez donc le
Sénat a créé une mission d'information à
la demande de du groupe
CRC
sur la gestion durable de l'eau qui a
été lancé donc en février
et dans le cadre du droit de tirage des
groupes et donc c'est une mission
transpartisane
nous avons comme rapporteur Monsieur
Hervé Gillet
président moi-même donc on a débuté déjà
nos auditions la semaine dernière
d'ailleurs c'était la première réunion
c'était avec les agences de bassin
et
[Musique]
on vise donc entendre on va entendre le
maximum bien sûr de
d'acteurs de la politique de l'eau et
l'objectif c'est de terminer nos travaux
avant la fin de cette manature puisque
il y a renouvellement en septembre donc
l'objectif c'est de terminer en juillet
si c'est possible
donc on a souhaité vous entendre parce
que les établissements publics
territoriaux de bassin et sont des
échelons essentiels de mise en oeuvre de
la politique de l'eau moi-même je suis
donc
membre de l'agence de bassin
Loire-Bretagne
représentant le Sénat
puisque maintenant on a des
parlementaires qui
sont qui représentent leur assemblée
dans les agences de l'eau ce qui est une
bonne chose et
c'est le changement climatique conduit
bien sûr à la mettre sous tension
l'ensemble des utilisateurs de l'eau
puisque on voit bien que l'année 2023
démarre un peu mal avec un mois de
février on n'a pas vu une goutte d'eau
après une année 2022 très sèche
également donc il y a une tension
qui risque de continuer avec les
utilisateurs de l'eau et ça risque d'en
s'entraîner une situation peut-être pire
cette année que on l'a vécu en
2022 donc vous avez produit voilà
quelques mois un livre bleu
pas si vous le lavez là on pourra
peut-être
et donc ce que nous souhaitons c'est que
vous puissiez nous apporter votre
éclairage
en s'appuyant bien sûr sur vos travaux
et puis en échangeant aussi sur le mode
de fonctionnement des agences de bassin
comment vous voyez les choses est-ce que
ça fonctionne bien est-ce qu'il faut
augmenter encore la démocratie
participative ou la réduire ou voir
comment est-ce que les moyens sont
suffisants qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour que ça marche ça fonctionne
mieux mais je vais laisser la parole à
notre apporteur Hervé JD qui va vous
poser à sa tante de questions et qui va
également vous faire des propos
introductifs
bien merci monsieur le Président cher
ami j'ai été assez court parce que le
laps de temps qui nous est imparti dans
cet agenda très contraint et vraiment
particulier je voulais vous remercier
bien sûr d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation vous réitérer aussi le
plaisir que j'ai de pouvoir suivre vos
travaux et la qualité de vos travaux
et par rapport à l'introduction du
président du président Pointreau
insistez peut-être un peu plus dans les
vos interventions sur la notion de la
gouvernance de la gouvernance
territoriale qui vous est cher un des
éléments également de mise en
perspective c'est comment on intègre
aujourd'hui les politiques de l'eau dans
notamment les politiques d'urbanisme
mais d'une manière générale comment
renforce les politiques de l'eau pour
qu'elles soient plus lisible aussi il
est question aussi aujourd'hui de la
contractualisation dans le cas des
contrats de plan état région de
s'interroger sur les compétences des uns
et des autres comment on peut voir
comment on peut pousser pour qu'elle
l'inverse au mieux dans un renforcement
des principes de la subsidiarité sachant
que aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
questions se posent par rapport à la
mise en oeuvre des compétences et bien
sûr derrière la capacité des moyens on a
pu évoquer aussi la gemapie qui ne peut
se mettre en œuvre que de façon
différenciée mais la politique des
moyens est pas toujours au rendez-vous
également
sur sur ces sujets et pour conclure je
dirais en quelques termes aujourd'hui le
but du jeu c'est d'aller plus fort et
plus vite en mettant en parallèle la loi
accélération des énergies renouvelables
il faut mettre en place en tout cas
aujourd'hui tous les éléments pour
accélérer également la mise en place de
politique de l'eau qui soit les plus
résilientes et les plus efficaces
possibles c'est peut-être le chapeau
aussi un peu général de l'intervention
de l'ensemble des acteurs
voilà je vous remercie et puis je vous
laisse donc la parole
sachant qu'on précise bien que on est
bien là dans une plénière donc il y a
une vidéo une il y aura un compte rendu
officiel donc on n'est pas en off je me
précise
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le rapporteur
sénateur et mesdames messieurs merci de
nous accueillir pour être très
intéressant pour nous d'avoir l'occasion
de de mettre en avant les sujets qui
nous occupent quotidiennement sur les
territoires peut-être rappeler
simplement que l'association des élus de
bassin comme son nom l'indique c'est une
association d'élus qui réunit en son
sein aussi bien des épages que des EPTB
ça veut dire que l'idée n'est pas
nécessairement de créer une association
qui porte une structure mais plutôt qui
porte une légende qui s'investissent au
quotidien sur un sujet qui lui trouve
fondamental et nous n'hésitons pas à
associer avec force dans nos travaux
aussi bien les élus que les directeurs
de structure en un mot tous ceux qui
font la gestion de l'eau alors on n'aime
pas ce mot mais du grand cycle de l'eau
sur les territoires au quotidien
on représente l'immense majorité de ces
établissements même si tous ne sont pas
adhérents il faut le dire tout de même
mais nous avons un nombre d'adhérents
tout à fait significatif et vous l'avez
soutenu monsieur le rapporteur nous
avons un livre nous avons fait paraître
un livre qu'on a appelé livre bleu parce
que il nous était nécessaire de rendre
un petit peu un avis après pas mal
d'années de réflexion et de et de
travail sur l'état des choses l'état des
choses aujourd'hui sur la question de
l'eau
évidemment il est d'actualité brûlante
mais en réalité il est d'évolution lente
et prévisible depuis pas mal de temps et
c'est bien la question qui nous occupe
le plus c'est nous avons largement perçu
les difficultés qui deviennent de plus
en plus prégnantes sur cette question de
l'OTAN lorsque les phénomènes sont
importants et paroxystiques provocant
des inondations qui nous posent des
difficultés que lorsque elle vient t'a
manqué et c'est sans doute ce qui
aujourd'hui nous nous inquiète le plus à
raison ça nous inquiète le plus sans
doute pour l'alimentation des hommes
mais pas seulement ça nous inquiète
aussi pour l'état de nos biotopes et
l'état de notre biodiversité il s'est un
sujet d'une importance cruciale ce sujet
mérite bien sûr d'être observé avec
l'urgence au sens qu'il est temps de s'y
intéresser avec beaucoup de soins pour
autant nous défendons l'idée que il
n'est pas nécessaire tout de suite
d'engager sont dans la précipitation des
mesures dont les portées ne seraient pas
suffisantes et nous appelons très
largement à repenser ou à continuer
d'approfondir plutôt à continuer
d'approfondir les les la structuration
qui mène et qui préside à la gestion de
l'eau dans notre pays depuis longtemps
la France a montré toutes ses capacités
en la matière et après preuve d'une
grande qualité et je vais laisser mon
mon collègue Frédéric monoscille
expliquait pour nous qu'est-ce qui est
important de maintenir et de mettre en
place et comment il est essentiel face
au sujet qui nous occupent non pas de
tout changer de renverser la table mais
d'intensifier ce que nous avons déjà su
construire de le rendre efficace et de
le rendre présent sur l'ensemble du
territoire on a Frédéric oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur mais mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
de votre accueil j'ajouterai peut-être
en préambule mais on est contraint
d'aller assez vite mais quelques mots
pour dire que vous avez fait référence
au livre bleu le livre bleu repose sur
dessus enfin sur deux fondants
fondements le premier qui consiste à
rappeler que selon nous l'eau est un
bien commun
et la deuxième chose ça vient d'être
appelé à l'instant par mon collègue
Bruno Forel c'est que la politique de
l'eau en France en tout cas par bassin
versant est un marqueur fondamental
auquel nous continuons d'être tout
particulièrement attaché et donc
on y reviendra peut-être dans les
échanges nous considérons qu'il est il
est temps de se de le rappeler de
manière assez vigoureuse notamment
depuis la mise en place de la gmfi qui
je le rappelle non seulement ne couvre
pas l'entièreté des thématiques
relatives à ce qu'on appelle
traditionnellement le grand cycle de
l'eau mais qui en plus renvoie au bloc
communal Dans le cas d'espèces aux EPC
fiscalité propre au métropole où elles
existent et non pas que nous remettions
en cause ce principe en revanche nous
considérons que il manque aujourd'hui
d'outils qui garantissent si j'ose dire
la cohérence de
à l'échelle du bassin versant et c'est
précisément l'élément sur lequel je vous
dis je vais vous dire je vais vous dire
quelques mots le deuxième point ça a été
rappelé je crois par monsieur le
rapporteur notamment c'est que votre
Commission vise aussi à être dans des
propositions
dans des calendriers relativement rapide
et pas seulement un moyen et long terme
ce qui est un sujet une préoccupation
que nous nous partageons mais nous
pensons en tout cas de notre côté que
l'un n'empêche pas l'autre c'est à dire
que autant il y a en effet sans doute
des mesures et on vous en dira sans
doute un mot à l'occasion de nos
échanges qui peuvent sans doute
aujourd'hui renforcer simplifier les
dispositifs pour rendre l'action plus
rapide plus résiliente plus plus forte à
l'échelle des territoires mais en même
temps il y a quelques sujets qui nous
semblent des sujets notamment s'agissant
de la gouvernance de voir être entrevue
sur une échelle un peu de temps en tout
cas un peu plus longue et je vais donc
m'arrêter un instant sur notre
proposition aux matières de gouvernance
qui est la nôtre nous nous l'avons
évoqué dans le Livre bleu j'ai eu le
plaisir de co-présider dans le cadre du
Plan haut avec le président de l'agence
en Bretagne entre autres
un groupe de travail portant sur le
grand cycle de l'eau et aussi bien à
travers le livre bleu qu'à travers ce
groupe de travail nous en sommes arrivés
à formuler une certaine nombre de
propositions en matière de gouvernance
et la première qui nous semble
devoir être appelés pour nous c'est de
promouvoir une organisation homogène par
bassin versant sur l'ensemble du
territoire national ce qui n'est encore
pas le cas aujourd'hui
et qui nous semble être à nos yeux en
tout cas la seule solution pour
permettre à la fois des prises de
décision et d'action partager en commun
et à la fois à la bonne échelle concrète
comprise par
nos habitants et et les différents
acteurs du sujet sur les territoires et
enfin qui en a sur la cohérence qui nous
semble être un élément indispensable
pour maintenir cette approche
inversant c'est la raison pour laquelle
on nous appuyant sur des choses qui je
le précise existent puisque notre objet
nous n'est pas de dire il faut
révolutionner ou de laisser croire que
nous partirions d'une page blanche des
choses existent des choses fonctionnent
même sur le territoire mais nous pensons
que cette organisation selon nous doit
s'organiser autour de
clés voilà
si de notre point de vue doivent être
désormais mis en oeuvre à l'échelle de
l'ensemble du territoire national et
d'un établissement public de bassin pour
nous les deux
devant être intimement rattachés l'une à
l'autre
dans la mesure où
selon nous la clé et une instance à la
fois démocratique qui assure le fait que
l'ensemble des acteurs d'un même
territoire
partage et décide ensemble d'un certain
nombre d'orientation d'éléments de
programmation à la bonne échelle
et bien évidemment l'établissement
public de bassin pour une raison assez
simple c'est à la fois comme leur nom
indique des structures de bassin bien
évidemment mais qui ont vocation elle a
intervenir à la fois dans le domaine de
l'expertise puisqu'elles ont possèdent
un certain nombre bien évidemment
et
c'est donc ce couple là ce binôme là qui
nous semble aujourd'hui
de voir être à la fois renforcer là où
il existe et d'autre part
[Musique]
couvrir l'entièreté aujourd'hui du du
territoire du territoire national tout
ça nous semble aujourd'hui permettre à
la fois intrinsèquement la
différenciation est aussi un élément
auquel nous sommes très attachés puisque
je rappelle que nous sommes une
association d'élus et des lilocaux voilà
qui qui intervenont sur ces sujets
différenciation à la fois en termes
d'enjeux d'acteurs et de solutions et en
même temps qui nous semble permettre ce
dispositif d'apposer des règles
générales de fonctionnement et de
financement ce qui est un élément
évidemment important et
[Musique]
on peut ce que je fais à un certain
moment pour éclairer
l'intérêt c'est de voir aussi
l'articulation entre
les syndicats porteurs
la façon même dans le BTV fonctionne
merci à chaque fois je l'oublie celui-là
la façon dont le PTB fonctionne ou
associe ces parties prenantes peut tenir
compte d'une différenciation
territoriale et que par contre dans la
philosophie même de fonctionnement de
l'EPTB le but du jeu c'est qu'on soit
quand même relativement homogène sur le
plan national et d'assurer la cohérence
à l'échelle du bassin versant ce qui
nous semble être un élément fondamental
pour ne pas perdre ce qui quand même
constitue le fondement de la politique
de l'eau en France mais qui a fait école
par ailleurs et donc je crois l'ensemble
des experts s'accorde à dire que c'est
ça reste et ça demeure bien évidemment
la bonne la bonne la bonne échelle j'y
ajoute mais on aura peut-être l'occasion
d'y revenir dans le jeu de
questions-réponses bon j'ai évoqué les
questions de financement leur a sans
doute l'occasion d'y revenir et puis ça
a été dit et ça c'est un point fort
auquel nous nous sommes également très
attachés la gélatine notamment a
renforcé nous pensons que depuis le
début la question de l'eau et emprunter
en particulier du Grand Cycle relève
aussi des politiques en règle générale
d'aménagement du territoire et ça c'est
quelque chose qui me semble aussi
extrêmement intéressant on a vu
récemment les débats qui se sont ouverts
notamment je pense dans le Sud avec ce
maire qui a pris la décision par exemple
d'interrompre pendant toute une période
les permis de construire bon voilà des
sujets qui nous montrent bien que il y a
tout ça est parti intégrante d'une
politique d'aménagement du territoire et
que le développement du territoire sur
le plan économique sur le plan de de sa
population sur le plan touristique sur
le plan agricole naturellement etc on
voit bien que ne peut pas se passer de
comprendre lignes de compte le sujet de
l'eau et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous pensons en effet qu'il faut
renforcer le lien j'allais dire
organique entre la politique de l'eau et
l'ensemble des documents d'aménagement
ça nous semble là aussi un élément
important à la fois parce que
il aura bien évidemment toute sa
pertinence dans le cadre de perspectives
d'aménagement et de développement des
territoires mais aussi parce que ça
viendra renforcer la gouvernance de
l'eau dans la mesure où on voit bien que
si on la laisse un peu seul dans son
dans son créneau si j'ose dire sans la
mettre plus qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui
en résonance avec des sujets qui
préoccupent beaucoup les acteurs locaux
et les élus en particulier
tout ça viendra nourrir de notre point
de vue de manière tout à fait
intéressante c'est différents sujets et
puis je vais m'arrêter là simplement je
voulais dire vous comprenez bien parce
que des fois notre discours enfin ce que
l'on porte je vois bien que notamment
pour les non initiés on dit oui mais il
nous renvoie encore à une espèce de
technostructure de machin d'abord pour
vous rappeler que tout ce que l'on vient
d'évoquer existe donc on ne propose pas
d'ajouter des échelons supplémentaires
on propose un de les renforcer en
assurant leur développement sur
l'ensemble du territoire
de les renforcer en termes y compris
d'interpénétration avec d'autres
politiques publiques et en particulier
celle de l'aménagement du territoire de
l'urbanisme pour ne citer que celle là
et trois vous aurez compris que pour
nous
cet articulation clé EP établissement
public de bassin c'est à la fois
l'assurance d'une démocratie locale
renforcée avec le rôle de l'ensemble des
acteurs qui nous semblent aujourd'hui
indispensables quand on voit à quel
point les tensions s'exercent sur ces
sujets là on pense que dès la base il
faut mettre tous les acteurs autour
d'une même table que ces acteurs
réfléchissent ensemble en tenant compte
des spécificités de leur territoire des
orientations à moyen et long terme qui
doivent être les leurs et de se doter
d'un outil opérationnel d'expertise mais
aussi par subsidiarité de maîtrise
d'ouvrage que sont les EPT et qui
garantissent à nos yeux encore une fois
la cohérence à l'échelle du bassin
versant voilà pour le chapitre
gouvernance
un mot peut-être pour pour vraiment bien
faire et tenter de de d'illustrer au
mieux notre positionnement en réalité
tout le monde en est conscient et on en
est de plus en plus conscient l'eau
n'est pas un élément de la nature parmi
tant d'autres rapprocher un petit peu
l'autre micro de votre bouche pardon
l'eau n'est pas un élément de la nature
parmi tant d'autres c'est un élément
fondateurs c'est l'élément essentiel et
les études prospectives qui sont menées
aujourd'hui nous le montrent avec clarté
en vallée du Rhône il y a eu une
présentation de l'agence Euromillions
Méditerranée Corse qui a été faite il y
a deux jours on a une augmentation des
débits d'étiage enfin vers les tirages
de
40%. et on prédit sur la totalité du
territoire national français une baisse
drastique des ressources
météoriques donc nous sommes face à un
vrai sujet y a-t-il donc un endroit sur
le nationale où la question de l'eau ne
se poserait pas sûrement pas
vraisemblablement nous aurons à résoudre
ce problème partout l'administration
globale du territoire a été faite et
construite autour de l'urbanisation
autour de la capacité de faire
organisation sociale sur l'ensemble du
territoire c'est bien normal mais l'eau
répond à une organisation à une
systémique différente à une systémique
par bassin c'est la conscience qui avait
été au moment des années 60 quand les
quand les premières lois ont été
construites sur la gestion de l'eau ça a
été l'idée c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
des grands bassins versants avec des
districts des agences de l'eau
aujourd'hui il faut descendre plus bas
dans la granulométrie de l'analyse de la
compréhension et des outils c'est
pourquoi nous disons il faut reproduire
une un dessin une carte administrative
qui se cale sur l'administration le
dessin nécessaire à la bonne gestion de
l'eau elle n'est donc pas connexe avec
les communautés de communes les
départements les régions ou les communes
il faut donc permettre à ces
établissements là de se retrouver autour
d'un établissement qui gère à la bonne
échelle
au bon dessin de la gestion de l'eau
c'est pourquoi nous mettons en avant
l'établissement public de bassin
pourquoi appuyer sur les clés comité
commission locale de l'eau pour ne pas
réunir que les représentants légitimes
et on sait pas nous qui allons dire le
contraire nous sommes donc des élus
locaux donc pour nous la démocratie
proximité était essentielle mais nous
pensons qu'aujourd'hui au regard des
usages de l'autre tant agricole
touristique industriels et aussi les
préoccupations environnementales puisque
la nécessité de laisser de l'eau à la
biodiversité et tout tout aussi urgentes
il faut créer ces commissions locales de
l'eau partout ou de chacun peut discuter
alors on nous obser que il y a parfois
des endroits où il y a des problèmes
bien que une commission locale de l'eau
et puis exister ben oui
est-ce que parce que un outil existe
qu'à chaque fois il est parfaitement
pertinent est-ce que parce que de temps
en temps le marteau ne touche pas le
clou le marteau n'est-il pas un des
meilleurs outils pour enfoncer les clous
oui c'est sûr les commissions locales de
l'eau ne peut pas résoudre tout une
résout pas toujours tout mais sans cela
le dialogue ne peut pas s'organiser
c'est le lieu du dialogue c'est le lieu
de l'échange et c'est sans doute le lieu
où l'on peut le mieux déminer les
inconvénients ou les incompréhensions
qu'il y a à créer un ouvrage
supplémentaire soit de protection soit
de l'eau
et en même temps puisque les collègues
seront peut-être aussi amenés à poser
quelques questions pour des éclairages
un peu plus approfondis dans le cadre
des clés on est bien adossé au niveau
des sages schéma d'aménagement de
gestion de l'eau des eaux et de ce
côté-là on est bien stage ça aussi dans
une forme d'articulation pertinente qui
qui doit aussi se faire et la question
de la clé c'est aussi la question
derrière de la politique des moyens par
rapport aussi la mise en oeuvre des
sages comment les finances aujourd'hui
puisqu'une des critiques souvent c'est
de dire on a passé beaucoup de temps à
les concevoir mais on passe énormément
de temps à pouvoir les mettre en œuvre
parce qu'on a des difficultés pour
mobiliser les moyens
sur la question
simplement moi je voulais ajouter
quelque chose est-ce qu'on a pas aussi
besoin de simplification
dans l'organisation de la gouvernance de
l'eau parce que les nos citoyens n'y
comprennent plus rien entre les comités
de bassins les agences de l'eau les
sages les stages les clés les machins ça
finit par être est-ce qu'il y a pas une
simplification à effectuer et puis la
deuxième question je voulais simplement
savoir pour notre information
dans quelle agence de l'eau est-ce que
vous êtes membre vous êtes certainement
d'une des agences de bassin et dans quel
collège vous êtes dans ces agences de
bassin ça m'intéresse pour savoir
comment moi c'est Normandie au titre de
l'EPTB celle dans lac
et en tant qu'élu local
je suis membre du conseil de comité
syndical de l'EPTB au titre du conseil
départemental d'accord je suis élu et en
suivant des conseils administration de
l'agence Rhône militaire en écorce et
membre du comité de bassin au titre de
ma présidence de l'EPTB sage SM3A donc
qui s'occupe de la rivière Harve qui
part de
Mont-Blanc et qui va jusque
au lac Léman dans larve et après dans le
Rhône
de mes de mes de mes sénateurs de deux
d'entre en tout cas merci d'être là
sur la question des financements je
pensais un vrai sujet là alors et puis
un mot quand même sur la ouais sur la
simplification un mot rapide sur la
simplification en ce qui me concerne
pour donner mon sentiment je crois que
si on a créé des outils c'est souvent
qu'on avait quand même besoin de
résoudre quelque chose en revanche c'est
peut-être de la manière dont on
construit des outils qu'il y a des
interrogations à avoir et la
différenciation
entre les territoires
honnêtement on a bien du mal dans ce
pays à laisser vivre la responsabilité
la liberté locale
un sage c'est pas forcément quelque
chose qui doit être pléthorique ni
immense simplement lorsqu'on l'écrit ou
lorsqu'on le structure de manière à
devoir répondre à une quantité
invraisemblable d'item on a le même
problème avec les schémas en
territoriaux les scottes font le même
problème je pense que on pourrait
simplifier les procédures et simplifier
les outils et permettre simplement au
débat à la rencontre à la construction à
l'échelle des territoires d'aller
chercher les sujets dont on a besoin et
c'est peut-être comme ça qu'on arrivera
à mieux faire comprendre aux citoyens la
manière dont on
dans la vallée de l'arbre
l'entièreté de la vallée cotise à linger
Mappy et de manière partagée entre
l'amour et la valve avec une clé de
répartition qui permet de la solidarité
et ça marche très bien et ça nous permet
de travailler mais il y a des sujets le
grand cycle de l'eau on n'aime pas ce
terme-là on l'emploie la question des
services que une zone humide restaurer
ou qu'une une forêt alluviale de bonne
qualité apporte comment est-ce qu'on la
travaille la gymapine correspond pas
réellement à ce genre de de choses donc
pour nous la question du financement est
essentielle c'est pourquoi on serait
intéressé autour de l'eau pluviale
autour de cette présence de l'eau qui
est de l'ordre du Grand Cycle que l'on
ados à ces établissements publics de
bassins une compétence spécifique qui
soit une compétence de bassin qui
s'appuie notamment sur la gestion de
l'eau plus-value qui permette en
aménagement du territoire d'être un
appui sérieux aux collectivités aux
communes aux côté de commune dans cette
gestion quotidienne et qui permettent
aussi d'engager des travaux qui seraient
sur le sur tout ce qui va concourir à la
bonne qualité de la présence de l'eau
sur le territoire tous les entretiens de
la biodiversité et du système général de
la nature qui permet une qualité d'eau
les régions et les départements par leur
compétences en matière d'environnement
pourrait s'associer et retrouver en
soutenance des EPTB trouver une capacité
d'action et un outil de démultiplication
de politique sur lequel elles sont ces
deux niveaux de structure sont déjà
présents
j'ai là parce que vous vous l'exposez
d'une manière un peu méta et c'est bien
que on peut-être on y revienne un peu
plus précisément en fait il y a des
contre si je décrite il y a des
contributions efficaces qui peuvent être
apportées à partir du moment on intègre
les politiques à tous les niveaux et
notamment au niveau des plu aussi des
pluies parce que la gestion du fil de
l'eau si le PLU et le PLU contribue à
développer des zones humides par une
meilleure gestion des eaux pluviales
c'est donc des contributions bénéfiques
pour un bassin sous bassin on est je
pense qu'on est bien d'accord là-dessus
et du coup ce qui serait intéressant
c'est de voir comment au travers d'une
complémentarité d'intervention sur des
niveaux de collectivité on peut financer
on peut améliorer le financement de ces
politiques
sachant que sur la j'ai Mappy on a un
problème aussi aujourd'hui il y a de
grandes différenciations entre des cours
d'eau très structurants et très
importants pas forcément que des fleuves
et puis parfois un chevelu qui nécessite
beaucoup moins d'investissement or la
nature de la politique réglementaire
telle qu'elle est définie et
législatives fait que c'est le même
niveau globalement des outils qu'on peut
mobiliser donc là on voit bien qu'on a
un problème c'est pas tout à fait pareil
j'ai bien reformulé pour que les choses
soient bien claires
personnellement j'adhère à ce type de de
démarche mais il peut y avoir débat bien
sûr sur sur ces sujets là
peut-être sur la question du financement
dire également que au-delà de donc de
du financement en investissement du
financement très opérationnel de d'une
politique très lisible nous appelons à
ce que on soit autour de cette
compétence on soit en capacité de
mobiliser un financement pérenne sur des
questions de planification sur des
questions d'ingénierie
et pour nous l'établissement public de
bassin et le lieu d'une ingénierie
partagée sur ce sujet
c'est pour nous un endroit où on
pourrait permettre collectivités à
l'échelle locale parce que le l'eau la
réussite de la politique de l'eau dans
le dans l'autre dans notre pays elle va
s'appuyer sur les efforts des mers sur
les efforts des conseillers municipaux
sur les efforts des départements sur les
efforts de l'échelle locale et et c'est
bien cette énergie là qu'il faut arriver
à mobiliser qu'il faut arriver à fédérer
et donc pour nous il serait possible de
permettre à cette énergie de se
concentrer sur un établissement public
qui traite ces sujets et qui bénéficie
d'un soutien d'ingénierie un bout du
plafond un bout du de la redevance une
des contributions pour des services
rendus sur la nature tout un ensemble de
choses qu'on peut développer et sur
lequel il y a lieu bon sens de
d'approfondir une réflexion
je suis compléter sur une petite
inquiétude mais peut-être qu'elle ne
restera qu'au stade de l'inquiétude
c'est pour ça que y compris sur la
question des financements les
financements pour investissement c'est
une chose et personne ici ne viendra
dire qu'il ne souhaite pas que il y ait
des investissements qu'il y ait des
financements plus importants qui ne le
sont aujourd'hui en termes
d'investissement mais sur par exemple
typiquement la question l'ingénierie qui
est quand même un sujet majeur pour
l'échelle de collectivité sur lesquelles
par exemple s'exerce la gélatine qui ne
peuvent pas disposer forcément de
l'ensemble de ces outils on voit bien
que si il devait être fait le choix à un
moment de
m'orienter les financements
de manière trop importante de voir quasi
exclusive que sur un volet
investissement en perdant de vue le
volet fonctionnement
on ne marcherait pas de manière
équilibrée et donc je dis ça parce que
ici ou là
Brice sur ces questions là c'est
d'ailleurs une tendance qu'on retrouve
ailleurs que dans la question de la
politique de l'eau qui sur le papier
peut être tout à fait enthousiasmante et
sympathique mais qui a nos yeux
seraient de la même serait la même
erreur que si on dit on dit ceci est clé
et établissement public de bassin faut
marcher sur nos deux jambes or
aujourd'hui on est à un moment parce que
là aussi il y a une autre chose par
donnez-moi que je voulais donc voilà je
voulais attirer votre attention sur
cette préoccupation là attention à ce
que tout n'aille pas ou de manière trop
massive qu'à l'investissement parce que
on rentre dans une période qui
d'ailleurs va finir par ne plus être une
période de crise là aussi je voulais
rappeler un tout petit mot parce que
c'est un discours qu'on entend beaucoup
parmi notamment les services de l'État
l'état disons moi de manière régalienne
je gère les crises
on tape sauf que s'agissant de l'eau le
problème c'est que la crise finit par
s'installer donc la crise finit par être
en réalité autre chose qu'une crise mais
en fait une situation qui évolue et on
vous évoquez monsieur le Président ce
qu'on a connu l'été dernier les craintes
que l'on peut avoir pour l'été prochain
qui elle-même voilà faisant suite
elle-même si on ramène sur une décennie
on voit bien que on parlait de soutien
des Tillages à scène Grands Lacs on est
largement au dessus des périodes retours
enfin de de soutien des tirages que ne
le prévoit nos règlements d'eau depuis
50 ans bon donc là aussi c'est pour ça
que la notion d'urgence de de prise en
compte rapide et d'amélioration rapide
et quelque chose que nous partageons
bien évidemment mais attention
si on ne prend pas garde à retrouver
aussi un peu la notion du temps long on
craint voilà que nous passions à côté
euh d'un certain nombre de choses et
parmi les éléments de simplification
parce que je partage monsieur le
Président on partage tous le fait que on
en parle beaucoup mais on voit pas qu'on
voit pas venir grand-chose bon d'abord
un il nous semblerait et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous on pousse à l'idée
d'une organisation
identique sur l'ensemble du territoire
ça nous semble déjà être un élément non
à la fois de simplification mais surtout
de lisibilité de visibilité parce que ce
qui rend parfois très incommodant pour
les gens non initiés d'y voir clair sur
un certain nombre de sujets comme celui
de la du grand cycle de l'eau qui est
particulièrement complexe et ardu je le
concède c'est que comment ça n'est pas
forcément organisé de la même manière
partout
ça rend encore plus compliqué les choses
deuxièmement on parle par exemple du
sage et d'usage on pourrait on l'avait
d'ailleurs proposé dans le cadre du Plan
haut réfléchir à peut-être les repeigner
un tout petit peu pour les rendre dans
leur dans leur conception peut-être plus
simple qui ne aujourd'hui bon vous avez
eu jadis alors oui parce que ça veut
dire qu'on mobilise des énergies des
élus des experts des acteurs sur des
documents qui s'avèrent parfois
extrêmement contraignant dans ce qui
nous demande
dans dans pour les voir aboutir et et
valider en tant que tel
sans que pour autant et c'est là où je
voulais en venir
ils ne trouvent de traduction parce que
c'est bien pour ça que si on ne passe si
on est que sur la multiplication de
documents mais qui a un moment ne trouve
aucune traduction visible concrète pour
à la fois les élus et eux-mêmes mais
pour leur population évidemment que ça
renvoie à cette idée que bon finalement
on est dans l'entre-soi où on fait des
bons et donc on pense qu'il y a
peut-être l'un des pistes il faut voir
avec notamment un certain nombre de de
d'administration centrale pour peut-être
revoir les choses et simplifier un peu
vous avez il y avait un exemple par le
passé alors maintenant la terminologie a
changé mais vous avez les fameux papy
d'animation qui sont de très beaux
outils moi je trouve pour en avoir
beaucoup lancé sur le territoire de
cette grande lac qui ont ce côté aussi
de gestion partagée avec l'ensemble des
acteurs et c'est quand même le gage je
vous assure c'est le meilleur gage
possible pour essayer d'atteindre le
consensus et je sais qu'on va en avoir
besoin de trouver en tout cas si ce
n'est le consensus de la convergence
mais vous aviez d'abord un bien papy dit
simplifié maintenant le terme a changé
donc il y a peut-être voilà là il y a
sans doute des pistes des pistes voilà
je vais peut-être laisser la parole à
mes collègues qui ont certainement des
questions à vous poser
Ludovic est Sylviane
une question une remarque qui va
totalement dans le sens des remarques du
président et de monsieur le rapporteur
mais aujourd'hui c'est l'organisation
territoriale on a quand même une
contradiction qui consiste à dire que
celui qui est quand même le plus à même
de faire une décision en matière de
schéma de l'eau c'est quand même le
maire ou tout du moins une vision d'un
élu local et qu'aujourd'hui on a quand
même une compétence qui tend en terme de
granularité à monter alors sur la grande
sur la définition d'un grand schéma d'un
bassin versant ça me dérange pas mais
aujourd'hui on a quand même aujourd'hui
un certain nombre d'élus qui se disent
ne plus pouvoir notamment sur la partie
gestion alors je sais pas aussi on a
peut-être pas assez dit la gestion
réduction d'eau potable sur laquelle n'a
plus grand chose à dire ou beaucoup de
mots à dire alors que la partie
assainissement les mers sont encore pas
mal confrontées notamment les petites
communes à la gestion de leur propre
assainissement avec des micro-stations
voilà là je prends moi il y a un vrai il
y a quand même un sujet et aujourd'hui
le fait qu'on est encore donné à
certains EPCI avec la dissolution
certains syndicats ça ne fait pour moi
que'éloigner la compétence des élus
locaux mais c'est un avis
c'est un avis personnel
concernant la partie gemapi alors voilà
moi je suis sénateur du du Haut-Rhin
l'Alsace c'est pas du tout de l'auto
satisfaction a été plutôt bien notée
parce qu'on travaille sur gmapi depuis
80 ans avec des ouvrages qui ont été non
seulement créés mais en plus entretenu
voilà bon il y a peut-être un petit côté
une petite influence germanique sur le
dossier mais en tout cas non mais c'est
important parce qu'on nous dit aussi que
dans certaines régions ça a du mal à
prendre il faut aussi dire là aussi dire
là où ça fonctionne pour autant on a
aussi des taxes comme comme tout le
monde et le fait que ce soit géré par
les EPCI n'a pas forcément été de
apprécié par tous les élus locaux mais
encore une fois voilà moi j'essaie de
contradiction là de nécessité d'être en
proximité vraiment sur cette gestion de
l'eau j'ai même aussi un autre projet
mais qui est peut-être pas là
aujourd'hui on en parlera peut-être pas
c'est sur la la capitalisation de la
connaissance aujourd'hui vous avez des
personnes qui sont absolument pas
intégrées dans les schémas de l'eau qui
savent exactement notamment des anciens
où ça passe d'où ça sort comment ça a
été fait et avec la dissolution des
syndicats et bien ces gens là ne sont
plus aux affaires et quand bien même un
jeune bien intentionné prenne la
direction d'une d'un sage ou autre c'est
quand même perdu et ça risque de l'être
voilà c'est un sujet un petit peu à part
mais je voulais aussi le dire pour le
temps que vous étiez là merci
alors s'il vient tu voulais non
mais ce que je pense à un sujet qui est
vraiment essentiel celui que vous
abordez là la question de la proximité
l'échelle à laquelle on est proche ou
pas d'abord je voudrais souligner avec
force que voilà moi je suis président de
PCI qui a récupéré la compétence au
potable mais je suis aussi maire d'un
village de 3500 habitants je suis pas je
ne suis pas un technocrate parachuté
donc cette question la présence et
l'investissement de l'échelle locale
dans les EPCI est essentiel et nous
devons développer une culture auprès de
nos élus de maire de petites
collectivités dire leur dire et leur
répéter et en tout cas en tant que
président de PCI je peux vous dire que
c'est quelque chose que je dis souvent
dire et répéter toute l'importance qu'il
y a de la présence et de
l'investissement et de la peur que les
petites communes font dans les EPCI
c'est sans eux rien n'est possible et
effectivement si nous ne réussissons pas
cette culture du partage et de la
Coopération je pense que nous aurons des
problèmes
j'insiste aussi sur un point important
effectivement la question de l'adduction
de l'eau à l'échelle des EPCI nous
paraît une nous en tout cas nous
défendons cette idée c'est la bonne
échelle ça n'est pas non plus une
échelle d'exclusion de la gestion de
proximité ça doit être une échelle de
coopération pas une échelle d'exclusion
mais la question on a on a tort enfin ce
sont de domaines connexes le tuyau qui
amène l'eau à l'évier ou dans la salle
de bain avec la question du Grand Cycle
mais ce ne sont pas les mêmes problèmes
pour cueillez un tuyau que de l'eau
arrive dans un tuyau il faut que
lorsqu'il pleut nous ayons correctement
géré l'arrivée de cette pluie que nous
ayons conservé des forêts qui sont
capables d'être été réservoirs
d'humidité que nous ayons une
connaissance de la pratique tout ça
n'est pas à l'échelle d'un village de
500 habitants
l'ingénierie la connaissance le la
compréhension du système hydrographique
pour vous donner une idée une vallée qui
est notre le PTB auquel je participe et
très petit à l'échelle du territoire
rien à voir avec celui de Frédéric c'est
un grand lac plusieurs régions plusieurs
départements par la vallée de l'arbre ça
part du sommet d'une montagne et comme
c'est très encaissé ça ça c'est très
assez rapidement ça se jette dans le
Rhône donc ça va assez vite nous n'avons
pas une cartographie précise du circuit
de l'eau depuis le sommet du Mont-Blanc
jusqu'à l'exhibitoire de l'arme nous
n'avons pas cette cartographie nous
sommes bien meilleurs qui à 20 ou 30 ans
mais nous n'avons pas ça n'est pas à la
portée d'une commune et c'est bien de ça
dont il s'agit il s'agit d'être capable
de répondre à ces doubles injonction
conduire de l'eau par le tuyau au plus
près de manière très efficace et aussi
mettre en évidence et aménager le
territoire pour que le la ressource soit
à disposition et c'est le même problème
que l'eau pluviale parce que l'eau
pluviale bien sûr c'est les mers qui
vont la gérer l'Europe pluvial mais ils
l'ont géré jusqu'aujourd'hui on l'a
beaucoup géré au tuyau depuis des
siècles on gère ça au tuyau on se rend
compte que ça pose des problèmes ça nous
pose des problèmes sur le régime des
rivières ça nous pose des problèmes sur
la réalimentation du sol en eau donc
aujourd'hui nous devons apporter au
maire dans leur gestion quotidienne dans
la construction de leur place de leur
rue des outils de la connaissance pour
qu'ils puissent travailler il ne s'agit
pas de décider à leur place il s'agit de
réunir la connaissance donner les moyens
de faire un travail de faire évoluer
leur capacité de travail au quotidien
c'est pourquoi un établissement public
de bassin pour nous c'est ce lieu là
c'est ce lieu ressources pour pouvoir
faire avancer le sujet de l'eau grand
signe vers le petit cycle
on va revenir sur la gemmapi parce que
moi j'ai un exemple concret
le long de la Loire je suis dans le Cher
et on longe la Loire sur une grande
partie du département et donc avec la
gemapie les communautés de communes ont
repris la compétence du Mappy des
communautés de communes de 10 15 20 000
habitants
donc ils doivent gérer les digues de
Loire donc des moyens colossaux qui
risque de d'absorber l'ensemble du du
budget de la Communauté de Communes or
on a un établissement public qui
s'appelle le PL l'état public Loire
qui gère
les poèmes d'inondation pour les
métropoles entre autres donc il y a pas
de souci ils sont bien bien gardés par
rapport
aux inondations le seul problème c'est
que on a réussi à faire passer un
amendement à la au dernier texte sur la
simplification et de Jacqueline Gouraud
je sais plus le titre exact ce pour
faire en sorte que les établissements
publics et une possibilité de reprendre
des compétences gemapi
pour essayer de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une une continuité dans la gestion
des digues de Loire parce que si vous
faites c'est une communauté de communes
fait des travaux ils ont les moyens ça
marche bien mais si la communauté de
communes à côté ne fait rien ça c'est
comme si on
pisser dans la violence excusez moi
l'expression mais c'est c'est dramatique
quoi et donc on a voté
l'expérimentation la possibilité
expérimentation on a interrogé le PL
et le PN nous dit ben écoutez nous dans
les pas d'accord nous ça nous intéresse
pas du tout de gérer la gemapi ça
comment on fait
vous avez une jeux appliqué gérée pour
les métropoles qui a les moyens déjà de
de l'action de de réparer des digues qui
coûtent des millions d'euros et refuse
la possibilité d'expérimentation donc
faut les obliger à ce moment-là est-ce
qu'il faut est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez vous de ce type de situation
est-ce qu'il faut les obliger les EPL à
les établissements publics à rentrer
dans les jeux dans les jeux mappy's qui
me paraîtrait plus logique d'ailleurs
il suffit que les communautés de
communes permettez d'être parfait
complètement franc enfin je suis là pour
l'être
le mot obligation est toujours un petit
peu compliqué à employer mais face à la
nécessité de réagir et de s'organiser je
pense que la destination logique de la
gestion de la gemapi c'est
l'établissement public de bassins et
c'est lui qui doit permettre d'aplanir
les différences donc le PTB que je que
je gère
préside plutôt
fait ça
[Musique]
sur un ensemble lié avec les agglos les
communautés de communes les départements
éventuellement les régions quand ils
sont concernés donc ce qui peut
s'entendre par rapport de la
différenciation territoriale mais en
même temps si on va voir une politique
cohérente et homogène il y a une
réflexion de fond avoir sur le sujet
enfin sur ce sur ce sujet là bon nous on
n'a pas utilisé le terme obligation
parce que
il renvoie mais je partage exactement le
point de vue que vient d'être évoqué par
Bruno Forel bien que nous nous soyons
tous les deux dans des organismes qui
sont des EPTB l'un comme l'autre mais
qui par exemple en termes de gouvernance
n'ont pas grand chose à voir chez lui
chez mon ami Bruno il y a tous les EPCI
du territoire
que les EPCI sans faire de ma part
qui a 4 départements les trois de la
petite couronne plus Paris la ville vous
avez la métropole du Grand Paris vous
avez trois champagnes métropoles vous
avez l'Agglo de Saint-Dizier et vous
avez quelques EPCI qui sont en fait il y
a l'ensemble de ce que l'on appelle dans
le jargon les théories les territoires
aux risques inondations bon mais qui
fait que du coup et on a une région qui
est en l'occurrence la région grandèse
nous on pense que les EPT doivent être
des organismes ou l'ensemble des
échelles de collectivités doivent
pouvoir partager à la fois la
gouvernance au regard des compétences
qui sont
vous l'aurez compris pas tout à fait les
mêmes quand à la question de la
gymnastique je partage l'idée que à
terme les EPTB doivent
en tout cas prendre en compte ce sujet
là
parce que non seulement c'est un des
éléments même si encore une fois la
gemapi ne couvre pas de l'entièreté de
tous nos sujets mais c'est effectivement
la question y compris de la solidarité
qui se joue parce que voyez bien que
quand la métropole du Grand Paris a levé
la première fois la gymapi elle l'a fait
auteur de 60 centimes
multiplié par 7,2 millions prenez trois
Champas de métropoles qui avaient un
problème comparable à celui que vous
évoquez sur sur son régime d'endiguement
qui n'avait jamais fait l'objet du
moindre investissement pour la plupart
depuis la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale bien
22 millions d'euros d'investissement
pour une collectivité d'environ 120 000
habitants
la taxe j'ai mes pieds à 15 euros bon et
avec ça
et avec ça
ils refont le système d'endiguement
mais ils ne peuvent pas faire forcément
l'entièreté de tout le reste qui serait
pour autant nécessaire
dans le cadre de la mise en oeuvre de la
gemapie donc on voit bien là aussi que
s'il n'y a pas un moment un système de
gouvernance qui puisse introduire à
l'idée d'une espèce de péréquation
de solidarité à Montaval urbain rural
et qu'on ne renvoie ça qu'à l'échelle
des collectivités qui elle-même
perçoivent la fameuse taxe nonobstant le
fait que comme tout élu local
aujourd'hui de manière très
transpartisale le levier fiscal n'est
pas forcément celui sur lequel on appuie
le plus volontiers la conjoncture du
moment fait qu'on n'y a plus encore
moins de manière volontiers volontaire
pardon bon et on voit bien pour autant
que vous voyez 7 millions deux fois 60
centimes c'est une chose 15 euros x
120.000 s'en est une autre et pour
autant en matière notamment l'un
d'investissement on voit bien que les
sommes
sont comme une mesure au regard de à la
fois des angios locaux mais qui sont
aussi des enjeux de bassin parce que
vous voyez bien qu'un système
d'endiguement correctement entretenu
protecteur pour la zone urbaine de 3
nonobstant l'immédiateté du périmètre
c'est aussi une garantie pour que on
avale
le Parisien dans la zone dense et
peut-être un peu moins d'eau
qui n'en aurait et donc ça suppose que
on est cet outil selon nous voilà qui
garantissent cette cohésion à l'échelle
du bassin versant que sont les
établissements publics de bassin et donc
on va dans le sens que vous indiquez
alors après il y a la question
d'obligation mais bon après il peut y
avoir aussi des leviers parce que par
exemple vous parliez de le peignoir
par exemple on nous demande on nous dit
tiens l'état nous dit engagez-vous pour
les ptgge là les formidables il se
trouve que dans votre
IPTV oui non
les pecs pardon
engagez-vous le peignoir s'engage de
manière extrêmement volontariste sur le
sujet abouti un très beau document
plus-value au bout du bout du bout
vous prenez dans d'autres domaines vous
prenez les PT ge vous là aussi on dit
aux collectivités parlez-vous
élaborer des documents faites consensus
vous faites des PTG vous aboutissez à
des consensus qui parfois vous le savez
mieux que moi mesdames et messieurs sont
parfois fragiles tout ça tient d'une
espèce d'alchimie un peu curieuse entre
les relations l'intérêt général la
thématique abordée et
l'interpersonnalité des relations qu'on
peut entretenir les uns et les autres
au-delà de nos différences résultat des
courses quand l'État voit arriver le
péterge l'état s'autorise le droit de
choisir dans les différentes position
itives dispositions dans le petit je
sais qu'elle va financer celle qu'elle
ne financera pas ce qui a pour but non
seulement décourager l'investissement
mais en plus la plupart du temps de
rendre caduque le travail d'équilibre et
de consensus voilà des choses aussi sur
lesquelles on pourrait réfléchir merci
Madame blatrix
peut-être
vous avez évoqué la question de la
simplification et documents notamment
des sages voilà les pistes que vous
envisagez sur le sujet nous en dire un
peu plus sur les risques du financement
de l'ingénierie que vous avez évoqué et
peut-être aussi évoquer un autre sujet
bon le vous avez les syndicats de
rivière les EHPAD maintenant qui sur un
bassin versant
correspondait à une politique cohérente
mais par exemple long d'un fleuve comme
le Rhône parfois on observe qui manque
de coordination entre les structures
amont et avales et voilà c'est comment
essayer de de résoudre ce nœud au moins
sur mon territoire j'essaie de
difficulté là et puis on a aussi dans
ces structures type et pages parfois des
difficultés de gouvernance du fait que
les collectivités adhérentes souvent des
EPCI mais parfois des communes pour le
orgemapi ne transfère pas tout à fait la
même chose il transfert le chez Mappy
mais pas forcément tous les items du
haut j'ai Mappy sous qui complexifie
quand même le fonctionnement je vais en
même temps laisser la parole s'ils
deviennent Noël comme ça vous allez
pouvoir répondre
et conclure voilà
merci président et merci messieurs pour
vos propos très éclairants j'ai la
chance d'être
issu d'un territoire souvent cité en
exemple en matière de gestion de l'eau
et je tiens vraiment à saluer
l'engagement de Bruno Forel à la tête du
syndicat donc EPTB qui assure chaque
jour non seulement en qualité en
quantité et puis aussi en conflit
d'usage parce qu'on est soumis à de
nombreuses pressions de nombreux enjeux
sur ce bassin donc c'est un fait et on
l'oublie un peu trop souvent mais aussi
en matière de prévention des risques
naturels sur lequel là aussi les EPTB
font un travail remarquable notamment en
territoire de montagne moi j'avais juste
deux questions mais vous y avez déjà
partiellement répondu
vu la raréfaction de la ressource est-ce
que la conciliation des usages vous
paraît être correctement assuré en cas
de de tension hydrique et si ce n'est
pas le cas est-ce que vous auriez des
pistes de d'évolution législatives
réglementaires ou administrative à nous
suggérer et puis j'aurais aimé avoir
aussi votre avis sur la question du
réemploi des eaux usées sur lequel notre
pays est très en retard par rapport à
d'autres pays européens je pense à
l'Espagne qui qui réemploi peu près 20%
de ses eaux usées alors que nous nous
sommes qu'à 1% qu'en pensez-vous merci
quelques éléments d'abord peut-être vous
dire Madame qu'on hésiterait pas on
n'hésitera pas à vous faire suivre les
quelques réflexions qu'on peut mener sur
des sujets évoqués sur la question des
différences structurelles nombreuses qui
a et parfois les difficultés du coup qui
proviennent de l'originalité ou des
produits de structure qui sont pas
réellement des produits de raisons mais
plus des produits d'occasion ou
d'allongement politique c'est bien ça
quand on appelle il semble quand même
que
dans notre pays le fait que dans toute
commune de France il y a un conseil
municipal l'élu de la même manière avec
un règlement des assemblées qui même si
une liberté laissée doit ponctionner par
délibérations qu'elles doivent être
publiques tout ça est encadré ça permet
quand même une sorte de simplicité de
simplification du sujet en fait ce à
quoi on l'appelle c'est une structure
plus claire de cette gestion de et du
fonctionnement des établissements
publics de bassin et il est vrai que sur
des grands fleuves et notamment le Rhône
en plus c'est un fleuve qui n'est même
pas que national donc c'est dire le
Rhône c'est un vrai sujet ça longtemps
été une qui grande question est-ce qu'il
y aura qu'un établissement public pour
gérer le Rhône alors il y a l'agence de
l'eau est censé être un ordonneateur un
orchestrateur de de du début de la
frontière pas de la source pour le coup
mais du début de la frontière jusque
jusqu'à son exutoire
personne n'empêche dès lors que nous
aurons des établissements publics de
bassin correctement structurés armé pour
répondre à leur sujet personne ne leur
empêchera sous l'égide de l'Agence de
l'Eau d'organiser des coopérations qui
tiennent debout de la même manière
personne ne dit qu'il faut qu'il y ait
un établissement public de bassin pour
chaque micro bassin
on peut tout à fait imaginer un système
qui permette à un établissement public
de bassin de gérer et de faire vivre
ensemble même des actions qui sont de
l'ordre de l'EPCI sur la question de la
qualité d'une petite rivière ou d'un
petit cours d'eau nous n'appelons pas à
la disparition de toutes les habitudes
ou de tout les choses qui sont bien
faites nous appelons à une structuration
claire de cette question sur la question
du réemploi de l'eau si on le fait on
l'a pas beaucoup fait dans notre pays
c'est qu'effectivement c'est beaucoup
concentré sur le tuyau unique et que le
double tuyau c'est quand même
extrêmement coûteux en termes de
structure
et puis on a aussi des règlements
sanitaires qu'il faudrait adapter je
rappelle qu'aujourd'hui de l'eau qui
sort des produits qui peuvent sortir
donc de station d'épuration ne peuvent
être réglementairement utilisés comme ça
avec sabructo
mazel tov comme on dit si si ce qui est
un gros frein ce qui est un gros frein
quand même à l'utilisation des
sous-produits ou des déchets de
l'agriculture ou de l'épuration ce sont
les toutes les précautions sanitaires
moi je suis pas sûr qu'on y soit aussi
facilement que cela quand je vois
augmenter les toutes les les mesures les
observations de d'éléments nombreux et
diverses dans nos dans nos cahiers de
change de
oui oui bien sûr oui mais justement non
mais c'est enfin je pense qu'on a on a
pas mal de choses à faire mais
il paraît relativement évident que tout
réemploi de l'eau qui serait fait à bon
escient
ne peut être qu'une source de d'intérêt
ça va de soi à titre personnel
pardon de la vulgarité du sujet mais 40
litres d'eau
pour chacun de nos petits pipi c'est
quand même beaucoup
donc c'est un vrai sujet
oui
non mais juste sur la question de non
mais très rapide non mais sur la
question est-ce qu'aujourd'hui les clés
de répartition de la ressource bien
répartie etc la réponse est non
globalement sinon on serait sans doute
pas sur des situations de crise comme on
en connaît comme on va vraisemblablement
connaître d'autres qui nous posent
d'ailleurs nous à dire qu'il faut
structurer renforcer la gouvernance à
l'échelle des territoires pour en tout
cas veiller à améliorer ce sujet là et
juste un tout petit point parce que
quand même c'est une anecdote mais on a
eu les fameux rétex sur la sécheresse de
l'an passé je vous invite à regarder de
près mais vous savez qu'on est doté de
de préfet coordonnateur de bassin
et je vous rappelle que les arrêtés sont
pris par les préfets de département et
bien je vous invite je vous invite à
observer l'incohérence que l'on a pu
observer entre certains arrêtés en aval
et certains arrêtés en amont pendant que
certains étaient autorisés à la vélo
leur voiture d'un côté on embêtait les
autres bons je dis juste que puisqu'on a
des coordonnateurs de bassin comme leur
nom l'indique il serait peut-être utile
pour commencer voyez par des choses très
basiques que le corps donateur de bassin
vieille à coordonner ses préfets de
département pour qu'il y ait une forme
de cohérence et de lisibilité de
compréhension et de solidarité partagée
sinon là encore on rajoute
merci de nous avoir reçu voilà mais
n'hésite pas à nous communiquer aussi
des éléments qui n'auraient pas été
suffisamment soulignés et puis on est
dans une certaine agilité si vous voyez
aussi des sujets qui peuvent réémerger
avant la conclusion de de la mission
n'hésitez pas à nous interpeller et nous
les adresser ça sera avec grand plaisir
et merci beaucoup et puis bonne
poursuite des travaux jusqu'à dimanche
soir à minuit
dans la joie la bonne humeur et